have i ever played stafford over the
board
i have i played it once in an over the
board
it was an over the board uscf rated
blitz tournament
against an 1800 rated player
and i i won in this line this is maybe a
couple years ago
uh my opponent played bishop c4 here i
i won without too much trouble knight g4
castling queen h4
but that was during a time where
stafford was still
like relatively unknown
but if i had the chance i would probably
play it over the board again
at least in blitz or rapid
maybe in classical like just for the
just for the content
it would have to be against the right
player though
i think i would play stafford over the
board against maybe an older player
who i would suspect doesn't consume
content
on twitch or youtube
um yeah i know there is there's always
people asking for merch
um i i can answer that with uh
with one number 2021
that's my that's my new year's
resolution
but in the time being or for for the
time being
there is a merch command you can get the
banana canvas poster
um oh i got bananas i replenish my
my banana supply they're kind of
invisible
but high in fiber
okay let's play more games yeah um
yeah it's a more chill stream uh i'm not
in rush to play games so i'm trying to
to answer some questions provide some
value between games as well
[Music]
is the stafford gambit new or just
recently popularized
it's it's recently popularized it's been
around for a while
[Music]
um but
i'd prefer not to take most of the blame
oh let's play a saffron oh i still have
to play king's indian attack too
oh tagi that's a good suggestion tagi
with um
saying i need a i'm not rosen t-shirt
oh opponent's ready i'm scared
opponents playing so quickly and
confidently
but also
can i do math 1200 something points low
rated than me
is opponent gonna fall into the the
thing i just showed
i guess we'll see
now this is one of my favorite positions
in stafford because there's so many ways
right white can go wrong
like the two most natural looking moves
both kind of
are just bad for white
oh e5 e5 it's also logical looking
but after knight g4
white can't really effectively defend f2
[Music]
i feel like i've had this position maybe
once or twice
there's a funny line d4 it takes never
mind
ooh
how to do this so there's bishop f2 king
[Music]
e2
actually bishop f2 king e2 might be bad
for me
because then my knights attacked and
defending the bishop
but this is just uh winning the rook
i queen e2 and then i'll take the rook
and i'll be threatening queen h4 winning
a pawn
oh yeah i haven't done more predictions
it takes work i think mods if there's
any mods that want to
run predictions i mean don't overdo it
but you can you should have access to
the predictions command
so i'm calculating this this
there's a potential windmill so imagine
queen h4 g3
i oh i take on h2 i lose my queen never
mind
i guess it existed even without the
knight here
yeah that would be bad
let's just invade white's crib
i have two pieces on the first rank
before move nine
i feel like
i feel like christopher columbus
discovering new new territory
and just claiming it as my own
it's kind of a nice feeling but i also
feel kind of bad
but i guess that's what thanksgiving is
for you just have to be thankful
and then feast on the food
man what a position i mean stafford
gambit leads to fun positions but i
haven't had something like this i don't
think ever
yeah now i can take the pawn because the
the bishop
defends the queen from g1
and now the the knight and bishop
coordinate beautifully
against g3 and the knight prevents king
f2 night's so useful in the corner
despite controlling only two squares
so this game would not be complete
without
my favorite move g5
and g5 uh the goal is to
just remove the bishop and then win the
pawn and the pawn is pinned from behind
so yeah let's start with g5
what's material i'm up a rook i think
it's leech asks for telling me
yeah if g4 i would just take the bishop
if the bishop retreats i will have a
choice what to take with the
knight or the bishop and probably the
knight and just facilitate some trades
there is a cool line i could counter
attack my knight
and then what i can do i can take the
bishop i lose the knight
i take here yeah it's gonna happen
so i'm gonna get the pawn to g3 most
likely
yeah now the bishop have bishop and pawn
have a nice relationship
likening myself to columbus probably
isn't the best look for me yeah
yeah you're probably right about that
what's another like more more respected
world explorer
marco polo or lewis and clark
but those are two people genghis khan
the vikings yeah
oh chad is so knowledgeable neil
armstrong
johnny appleseed
some names i just haven't heard of
before
okay so now
i mean if if my rook wasn't here and
like out there with ta it would be mate
but that's not real life also hi akd707
welcome back
you're just in time for the grand finale
of this masterpiece
pawn is ready to promote but if i
promote then i lose the queen
so well i might do i might leave the
pawn here
and then try and
keep it company with another pawn
oh yeah there's one explorer that's
more probably more famous than all the
other explorers
it's dora adora the explorer
wait is this is it explore dora
no it's dora the explorer
i think okay let's take a pawn
with check forking the king of the pawn
i probably don't want to take this pawn
because it opens e-file
unless i do
what to do
h5 unfortunately it's kind of too slow
it loses
h pawn
so i think it's time it's time to
to cash in make a queen
and then i'll be up two rooks
as opposed to rook bishop in two pawns
for a night
okay
yeah dora is the best explorer
and the the worst explorer i don't think
anyone's said it yet
the the worst explorer is internet
explorer
i think everyone can agree
at least the people old enough to
remember
no offense microsoft
okay let's keep taking pawns
oh can i win the game by checkmating
[Music]
rather than
flagging i just want to make a queen
oh
and the bishop's always controlling
i think the the bishop wants to return
to its
its home
just attacking from behind
okay i'm sacrificing the bishop for a
good
cause or not
okay i'm seeing the the potential mate
rook h3
and bishop h3 mate it's hard to stop
it's really hard to stop oh white
stopped it
do i do it i could do it
just for the show oh i meant to i meant
to under promote
but the whole point was to sack the
queen and then okay that's meat
okay it was actually nice
and queen sack that queen was very
short-lived
it survived for half a move
what a game thanks for the game memo
type
this whole game was just a meme of some
type
that's what memo type means right
oh look what are my favorite t's uh
if this goes on youtube i'll leave a
link in the video description
to my amazon storefront where you can
you can find
a list of my favorite teas you can also
use the amazon command
in the twitch chat uh but shout out to
future youtube
people hope you enjoyed that
yeah so just uh just to show the opening
after bishop c5
um this move this move and this move
are all mistakes or blunders
because of knight g4 and this is black
spread in this position
so the two best moves are either bishop
e2 or h3
or even f3 um
i mean these moves look passive but
like kind of needs to to defend
and there are still there are still
traps with like all these lines
which i've shared in previous videos
so i'll have to add this to uh to my
stafford gamut playlist